foreign
[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream q and a segment 167.
what that's right yes that's right here
we are Dr Brett Weinstein Dr Heather
Hein back with you again we are going to
keep this tight today because we went on
and on and on we're in that first we
went on at length yeah in that first
hour okay so from the Discord that we
start every hour every every one of
these with a question from the Discord
server every week if you want to be in
on that you should join one of our
patreons and get access access to the
Discord
we have this week a choice between two
and I like them both I'm just going to
go with the first one
both of them warrant a lot more than a
off the cuff answer but let's let's give
this a shot
writers are often considered lazy or
unimaginative or anthropocentric when
depicting intelligent alien life as too
similar to humans but won't there be
some or even many features that end up
accompanying intelligence when it
happens to develop how different should
we really expect intelligent alien
civilizations to be
so I
wrote an entire yet unpublished science
fiction novel investigating exactly this
question and I do
think that there are different levels of
similarity so this question seems to be
getting at like the intelligence like
what will the intelligence be like but
in terms of the form it's it's easier to
critique and the critiques that I hear
more often are about the form that the
organisms take like the anatomy and
physiology and there is no reason to
expect
that uh anatomically and physiologically
intelligent life that evolves somewhere
else from totally different
um
information molecules you know from you
know not from DNA from the same original
building blocks if you go back far
enough but uh you know might not even be
carbon based right there's just any
number of forms that that intelligent
life could take so um more often you
hear a critique about
organisms other intelligent life looking
you know being bipedal uh having two
eyes now if you've got eyes at all you
probably are going to have two of them
rather than one and they're probably
going to be facing forward so that you
can uh so you can do depth perception so
there are some things like having two
pairs of things that you can triangulate
uh with regard to your sensor against
two nostrils two ears two eyes
but the overall form uh we shouldn't
expect inherently to repeat
um you know
I think you have to be open to the
possibility that things will not repeat
on the other hand the number of ways to
build something functional is more
limited than it seems you know there are
lots of
canonical forms and but radial symmetry
is a canonical form yep there's a
question about whether or not an
intelligent creature
is likely to have some of the
characteristics that we have for reasons
that may be less than obvious
and so but I mean to your to your point
that you raised in the first
thing that we did today I want to say
the first hour it's not right um you
know octopus yep don't look anything
like us yep right they've not only got
radial symmetry but you know they've got
an ability to their sense organs
everything about what they do is just
different right and yet they're highly
intelligent right and that's on this
planet right but they've got an image
forming eye of a separate Genesis that
functions very similarly with an
improvement actually right so image
image forming eyes yep built of
different stuff they may look different
uh will that show up on another planet
with intelligent life yes well organisms
that are highly intelligent have more
than one of them
probably yes right right
um all I'm saying is I think you have to
be open to any level of difference but
should expect
certain surprising similarities
um
so you know I don't want to get boxed
into saying oh it will be similar
because it can be very very different
but all I'm getting at is that the stuff
that led to our intelligence may be
um
more
constrained yeah but what like what I
mean that's what the question is so what
what do you think then well I think uh
emergent consciousness
uh is highly likely that emergent
Consciousness is
pretty likely to involve something
uh a mechanism that is not
I wouldn't be surprised to see
communication via sound I wouldn't be
surprised to see a pair of ears a pair
of eyes I wouldn't be surprised to see
two Sexes I wouldn't be surprised to see
sleep two sexes
sleep
uh sensory organs that may use the same
primary senses that we do or may use
electricity or magnetism or some of the
things that some other organisms on this
planet use but that we don't so much or
that see outside of our what we call the
visible spectrum sure only because it's
visible for us so yes you know sensing
the world
um by those things that are sensible
sensible Sensible
will happen and it may not look the way
it does for us but there is a limited
number of things that are sensible right
right so you know life is almost certain
to happen around a star that puts out
light that leaves a inexpensive
mechanism for figuring out where the
other objects in the world are
right but the kinds of stars that could
produce uh that that could have
planetary systems around them uh that
could have life on them are actually
somewhat variable and have different
Spectra sure that they Emit and
therefore the color sensing and the
temperature range in which these
organisms may live and therefore what
kinds of forms they could take could be
wildly different well
it's the point where you say you know
I'm open to any level of difference but
to the extent that it is likely that
given that photons are going to be free
that is to say you don't have to pay a
cost for generating them the way you do
with echolocation
that one
possibility is that you will see
creatures that take advantage of the
photons bouncing around that process the
location information about objects
in ways that are liable to discover the
same mechanisms that we have
and may be sensitive to different
spectrature may not be color sensitive
probably you know to the extent oh I
think there will be color sensitivity
um quickly evolving wherever you have
light sensitivity and light sensitivity
will evolve quickly yeah but it will be
but it may well be different and and
therefore reveal the world in a
different way yeah but you know that
would be a small difference
um to the extent I guess I'm proceeding
from what happened when we invented
sonar and then discovered how the sonar
of a bat works the answer was actually
there were certain canonical problems
that we solved very similarly to the way
that bats had solved them and therefore
the parallelism had nothing to do with
biotic parallelism it just had to do
with the fact that you've got certain
kinds of information that has to be
processed in certain ways and there are
most logical ways to do it in an
engineer can figure it out and select it
can figure it out but I would say I
guess in terms of locomotion respiration
um
even probably neurological like you know
whatever
all might be encompassed in that
capacity
um digestion
food acquisition as part of the
digestive process all of those could be
wildly different in on a different
planet with differences with with
different um originating conditions
and we know that in part because all of
those things we have examples of wildly
different things on earth yep uh and uh
the I I agree that I think intelligent
well that you know sensory systems
sleep is going to be a surprising one to
people but you know we make this
argument in in the book and
hunter-gatherer's guide that sleep is
likely to be a universal for you know
any any aliens that show up on Earth are
going to understand sleep just fine
there are plenty of things about us that
they won't necessarily have familiarity
with but let's sleep they'll get dreams
as well right
um
I would guess you know if a centralized
brain and there doesn't need to be a
centralized brain but if a centralized
brain uh the thing that we do with
lateralization and then tying it back
together with the corpus callosum
um so that so that you can both have
separate and unified at the same time
and in varying degrees is very useful of
course another way to accomplish that
would be something like
um you know an insect model of having
you know a lot of different systems that
um are connected to one another but
there's not one Central neurological
Clearinghouse
so you know the CNS the central nervous
system of some differently evolved
intelligent life form could look wildly
different but will they have sensory
input coming in yes well they have motor
input and and motor output yes is there
going to be highly intelligent life that
can't move
no because you need to you need the
feedback it's got to do something
equivalent yeah I was going to say you
know maybe at One Life Stage maybe like
you know just like babies right now but
um but no so so there's going to be
sensory and motor but it might happen
very very differently but there will be
those things but that's pretty broad yep
yeah I'm not I'm not sure how how far to
go I'm open to any level of difference I
expect to see surprising similarities
and I actually don't expect that we're
going to get a chance but I wish we
would it would be great
okay
first question from
darkhorsesmissions.com
tiny disruptions to fetal neural
development cause schizophrenic thought
disorder and severe problems with
logical inference
could microplastics or other toxins be
disrupting neural development and
therefore the true cause of much of the
illogicality of the work could wokeness
be a Neuropsychiatric dysfunction
so let me just say the the initial
sentence is a claim yep that sounds
right to me but I don't I don't know
that it's correct and there's no
reference and the word tiny strikes me
as a little bit too far probably so if
we take off the word tiny I'm just going
to repeat the claim which is the
disruptions the fetal neural development
cause schizophrenic thought disorder and
severe problems with logical inference
it's I won't say it sounds right it
sounds plausible but I've never heard
that before and I don't know I would be
surprised if we we actually had had the
tools to assess because it's such a
complex system with so many inputs at
the baby level that how do you know at
the point later that you've got
schizophrenia that it's because of
um constructions to fetal neural
development so I want to know what that
claim is based on yeah so that's that's
a that's a claim that the question is
starting with that we are saying maybe
but we don't know
um however
the rest of the question reads could
microplastics or other toxins be
disrupting neural development and
therefore the true be the true cause of
much of the illogicality of the woke
wokeness be a Neuropsychiatric
dysfunction
um
I think there's something here and I
wouldn't say the woke specifically I
wouldn't say
um you know I think as we alluded to
I've talked about
um not microplastics but um endocrine
disruptors uh both you know both
estrogens in the water and and endocrine
disruptors in the water may be deranging
us into chronologically may be partially
responsible for a tremendously larger
number of people actually being confused
about not feeling like they are the sex
that they are I don't think it's by any
means the only thing going on nor do I
think it's primary but I do think that
it's a problem so Plastics
yeah
I
do think we are disrupting all kinds of
things and that
um gender confusion is maybe partially
Downstream of it but I also think you've
got informational chaos and a
developmental environment that does not
provide proper feedback
you know when you screw up thinking
about something you're supposed to get
hurt and that is supposed to cause you
to get better at thinking and when we
have a system in which
your confusion about whatever it is is
you know fostered by a civilization that
is equally confused and interested in
you remaining confused it's not
surprising that you end up confused
uh so you know we've got
universities that are teaching you that
uh what two plus two equals is Up For
Debate
um that pedophilia may not be a bad
thing that men can become women
um so that is a system that is both
cause and effect yes confused people are
in that system but it is also a system
that is going to cause confusion and it
doesn't require anything chemical right
it's basically
a
um a failure of the feedbacks that are
supposed to make us get smarter which uh
you know
life has gotten very easy and that has
caused bad thinking to get purged less
well
yeah uh that said to the to the actual
question
um could there be some effectively
ecotoxicity uh that is contributing to
Mass confusion yes sure yes um and you
know I think it's more likely to you
know you've got a couple different ways
that that could work you could get uh
endocrinological confusion over
sex stuff because there are so many
xenoestrogens
you could get depression of
intelligence you could get the
disruption of the formation of
intelligence you know lead produces a
disc decrease in the capacity to think
and there is a part of me I was
forgotten what topic I was on but I was
thinking earlier this week
about the confusion that happens to
people when they climb to very high
altitudes or high elevations yeah um
where basically the hypoxia causes them
to make bad decisions about
climbing and descending and stuff like
that and it gets people killed and I'm
looking at it civilization and we're
doing a lot of stuff that could get us
killed and I'm feeling like if we had
hypoxia would we know it yeah right yeah
it's a little bit
too close for comfort the level of
confusion does strike me like what might
happen to oxygen starved Brands and I'm
not arguing it's oxygen starvation right
but
the equivalent yes people are very very
confused
um it you know if you were in a room
where the
breathable air was polluted or
low in oxygen do you reason well enough
to get yourself out of the room or do
you succumb to it
uh well some number of people look
around and at the point they don't see
anyone else panicking or leaving they
decide that it's just them yeah
and they uh yeah they Ash Conformity
them their way into death yep yeah
okay I had
I didn't the person asking the question
had the Tdap vaccination two times in
five years but I was still told to get
it while pregnant I got titers instead
the doctor never had anyone ask for
titers and they weren't covered by
insurance
that's not a question but a but a
statement I feel like we're asked
something
um last week yeah
um about
about whether or not to get I think it
was the Tdap
um during pregnancy and you know our
sense was why you would be getting any
vaccine while you're pregnant I don't
know
um and it's not you know is is there
some is there plausibly some situation
which might arise where that would be
the right move okay sure but
um I don't know yeah it's hard to it's
hard to imagine yeah
um I'm just saying it you know it's not
a blanket like absolutely no way under
absolutely no conditions could that ever
be the right move but um the default the
default assumption has to be that's not
going to be good for your baby and
um it should wait it should wait until
you don't have the baby literally on
board in order to get there it would
have to be
a disease with a strong likelihood that
you would get it yep a huge effect of
the vaccine on your ability to
tolerate the disease
a low indication and an affirmative low
indication of harm to fetuses which
would almost never be good enough but
you know in other words if the disease
that you're vaccinating for
is not rampant
then
it doesn't make sense to take that risk
even if in principle they're you know
were it to get you it would be
critically bad for you and or your fetus
if it's not out there in the environment
but if it is behavioral modifications
first if it is out there in the
environment then there's a strong
argument that you don't want to be
giving it anyway because you don't want
to provide an evolutionary landscape for
the thing you know you don't want to
encounter it while you're partial
partially immune so it would have to be
something like there was an outbreak of
a terrible disease in a place that meant
that you had a limited period of time in
which to gain immunity before you would
be likely to encounter it and that if we
vaccinate you now you'll have the
immunity by the time you encounter it
and if we don't vaccinate you now you're
liable to encounter it and fare badly
that's unlikely yeah
um and that is a possible scenario and
you know it also requires that you know
the vaccine is actually safe and
effective and the disease has a high you
know as a highly risk safe and effective
as far as we know and then to both you
and you know to both mother and and
fetus very hard for me to see in the
argument for this in in the case of a
pregnant person yeah and you know to to
the comment
um
yes get your titers done I mean this was
I mean we've talked about this before
but um you know we're both vaccinated
against rabies
and uh I think at 10 years it's
recommended and it's been a while since
we've done it at this point but at some
point 10 years after we originally
vaccinated
um they didn't they I don't even
remember where this would have been but
they whoever the doctors were did not
say go get your but your next rabies
vaccinations because it's been 10 years
to get your titers checked and see
because there's a good chance if you've
got healthy immune systems that you were
vaccinated 10 years ago you've still got
you know you've still got good immunity
and sure enough we we did yeah so
for all of these the idea of like oh
it's just been x amount of time
therefore you need y shot no like you
were all different human beings with
different kinds of immune systems in
terms of their health and their ability
to hang on to immunity and we you know
in any of these cases we should be able
to check titers before we agree to
another shot yeah I have one concern
about Titus which is that it's antibody
focused
is it entirely that's what they're
checking that is okay um you know
antibodies is part of a story the cells
are the other part of the story
and so it's not you know my guess is if
you've got the does the pro does does
that is that a better indication many
many years out or or no like if you've
still got antibodies a long ways out
isn't it's not a better indicator yes
it's more likely that your antibody
reaction will fade while you still have
T-cell immunity I believe yeah
um but in general the degree to which we
do not leverage titers and we just
inflict shots on you because they're
presumed safe is suspicious yeah yeah
all right
do you have advice for raising two boys
less than two years apart helping them
get along
um well I've got a piece of advice well
first I will say that our boys are
technically less than two years apart
but um but by like nine days
nonetheless I think our experience is
relevant enough um but they I
they did great they did great we did
have them in the same room for most of
their
Early Childhood I would never let them
out they're just in that room for I
think it was eight years but then we
opened the door like look at the Sun
you know look I mean no they slept in
the same room they had the same room yes
they had the same room and that now and
actually it was until they were like
14 and 12. something like that 11 and 13
14 12 something like that yeah yeah and
you know that you know I don't know what
happens if your kids don't get along but
my sense is good parenting results in
kids getting along and the having them
in the same room
uh causes you to work stuff out yep um
yeah no and they became um
yeah they were they're almost always
good to one another and uh when on
occasion they weren't we encouraged or
demanded that they deal with it first
that you know we we were not the first
line of defense
um uh for them against each other ever
they they were expected to
interact with one another first and
foremost as as the other human being in
the interaction and that you know that's
that should hold for any of the
interactions that you know if if the
parent is constantly coming in and
solving problems for the kid then the
kid learns that they don't have to solve
the problems for themselves
and um certainly getting in between
siblings as they are developing
knowledge of how to interact with peers
is going to be counterproductive
um anything else
I think so
we're just going to run through all
these questions very very quickly you
don't not have much to say well I I'm
not sure what to say I you know we have
two kids we did a lot of stuff that was
different we
talk to them like they were adults which
was hilarious at first and then resulted
in
um both of them talking back like adults
which I think is good
um yeah
don't protect them from everything I
don't I don't know I don't know that we
can say very much about them getting
along because they do get along and but
I mean this is not just about this is do
we have advice and you know yes we have
an anecdote in terms of our family but
uh I guess I would say uh also that
um boys are more likely than girls
probably to get um to get physical with
one another and and let them right like
you know don't don't
stop that every time it happens and you
know give them the space to do so and
um sure if it's not dangerous outside
encourage them to do it outside but
um but
do not shy away from their interest in
being physical at all and that's part of
how they're learning you know how to use
their bodies and how to be in the world
yep
have you heard of electricity
a proposed step post orality and
literacy by Greg Ulmer it explains the
web as a spirit world where lack of
ritual and Care lead to possession
as in of by Spirits or mimetic ideas
so that's sort of obviously I've never
heard of this before and there's a
language of sort of a woo language here
but uh
the idea that we are actually living in
in a in a third phase and I've actually
some have proposed that it's that the
the web world is more like an oral
culture less like a literate culture and
more like an oral culture but the idea
that it's got the rules of some third
type of
um
Society is interesting and I don't
I think I don't have enough information
here to say much more than that yeah I
would say have you heard of it nope yeah
um but there's definitely a vacuum that
comes from not having a tradition
conveyed
to
uh to offspring right there's a an empty
space niche-wise in in the soul and
it is not surprising that it gets filled
with lots of garbage in an online world
where people are free to float whatever
version of here's how to be a human
being they
are persuaded by
so you know this is a version of the
religion-shaped hole right religion
and I also think it is the case that in
recent history in the last few years we
have watched religious people very
frequently out compete secular folks
with respect to resisting bad thinking
that was being inflicted on them by uh
governments and
large institutions newspapers and the
coordinated narrative that came from all
of those things
so
I've a as we've we've talked about
extensively
even
scientifically minded people need to
figure out what to do with the fraction
of the model of the universe that we
can't fill in right which is not really
a god of the gaps argument but the point
is you have to be able to think
carefully about this and carefully about
that knowing that you don't know what
goes in between them and you have to
have some way to give yourself license
to jump in that you know if you convince
yourself
it's all one unified story and that you
are in on it then you're going to end up
telling yourself a lot of lies at the
places where we really don't know what's
going on so religious people have a very
easy one right they are licensed to jump
any Gap because you know because they in
general believe in a marvelous Creator
and so here are the things we understand
and hear the things we don't and we're
comfortable with mystery
um so if you put God aside
on the basis that he she or it fails to
exist
and you leave open therefore well how am
I going to deal with the mystery part of
what I'm faced with it's not surprising
that people get parasitized by bad
thinking it's a vulnerability and so
anyway I'm not sure I would describe it
according to the taxonomy that the the
person asking the question has presented
it does sound a bit woo but yeah there's
something something going on with um
memes
beliefs that have not stood the test of
time being way more contagious than they
should be by virtue of
um a mind opened by atheism and then
exposed to
bads
yes
um
I'm trying to remember I I don't I don't
have time to dig into my computer here
and find it but there are some um
generalities uh
what
together by I think it's Walter aung who
wrote this uh classic Treatise orality
to literacy
in the 60s maybe late 50s 60s early 70s
something like that in which he
describes the sort of the the canonical
if you will to use that the word of the
day here
um thing true things about oral cultures
versus literate cultures and I am I I
would I would have to go back and remind
myself of some of the differences
um between them but uh
you know one of the things
May
if I try to pull up any of them from
memory because it's been a while
um but the idea that there might be
third list you know a third set of
of structures of ways that we tend to
interact with one another
in this world that is dominated by uh I
don't know this says
um
the web you know maybe it's more than
the web it's social media some I don't
know exactly what the descriptor is like
what the fundamental thing or is an oral
culture versus a literate culture you
can tell what the distinction is so you
know you know what portion of your world
are you engaging in on the web that
makes it like that kind of a culture
um the idea that there might be
distinguishing features uh and maybe
it's not like a return to an oral type
of a culture but actually a a different
thing is intriguing to me and I'd like
to know more yep and whatever is going
on in the AI space is going to disrupt
this because it's going to be possible
to be a very articulate parrot
right
you're going to be able to save yes
wonderfully intelligent things that you
don't really understand or that you
think you thought of but you didn't
you've got it from this artificial
intelligence and uh yeah and it's not
you know people don't
there won't be the same
taboo against plagiarizing an AI
right like if you hear it if you know if
you go online and you and you do
something and it comes up on core you're
like well okay most people will have the
sense of like well I gotta attribute
this like this is where I heard this or
like you know because they know there's
a person behind it there's a person who
wrote that thing to them
whereas not you know knowing that that
thing isn't a person sort of takes away
the responsibility to honor it with
attribution yeah well in part people you
know people react badly
um if you plagiarize them right the AI
presumably doesn't care right
and
so people will be liberated they will
not get the feedback of yes
um doing it and
uh
I do it won't be as trackable either
right like I don't even think they will
understand they who the people the
people the people they're not going to
know what they're doing they're going to
think they are saying intelligent things
because they're going to get a reaction
from other people as if they're saying
intelligent things and they are
technically saying them but it's like
reading them it's like reading
Shakespeare and not understanding what
you're saying
right
yeah like reading it just for the meter
or something you could imitate
somebody's presentation of Shakespeare
that was very good emotive in the right
place right and the audience might
love it yeah and the point is oh I'm
pretty good with Shakespeare really
maybe you're not right yeah um so anyway
I'm I'm very concerned that
um people are going to take this the
issue of
you have to take what you deserve credit
for very seriously and not lie to
yourself about it in order to get
smarter and the fact that there's
something that probably is not going to
enforce this everybody has access to it
and so people are gonna leap to put
things into the public discussion
quickly that they've gotten from the AI
I I just don't see how this can't
uh I don't see how it's going to avoid
ending very very badly yeah
yeah many fantasy creatures have pointed
ears for instance Orcs And elves
what evolutionary benefit does this
provide and why don't we have them
I know this question
um
my first reaction was well they're cute
they're so cute okay but why do we find
them cute why do we find them cute we
find them cute in part
um
because
mammals who were so external penne which
is the like technical term for ears
obviously we have internal things that
we call ears but the external thing that
we call ears which for some reason we
use the same word for are technically
called Pine that's the fleshy part that
you can see that's a mammal synapomorphy
that's a shared derived characteristic
of mammals you know
and so
um imagine you know a cat
or a mouse or a bunny rabbit or even a
giraffe
and uh you could see them and they you
know they flick their ears they what is
it the caracal that does the my God the
just the most beautiful ear move ever
with a really long tuft at the end and
uh but all of these animals if you watch
them
um in real time but then especially if
you watch a slow motion video of them
they're just doing interesting things
with their ears that are yes them
sensing the environment but also
therefore if you're paying the right
kind of attention to them you can pick
up on ways that they are interacting
with the environment and maybe they're
communicating with them sometimes
they're actually using their ear
movements to communicate but more often
they're using their ear movements too
since the outside world and then that
can give you a sense of what it is
they're doing
ours are plastered against our head and
not attractive
yeah sorry all you dear fetishes out
there but like you know you know
compared to a cat's ears sorry we just
don't we don't have it going on and um
and it would be adorable if we not I
don't know about the elf thing with them
still plastic against that that seems to
me that there's no functionality to that
at all but if they're up here and we
could if you can move them yeah it's
actually about aim
um and the idea is the pointed ear for a
creature that can
pivot its ear the ability to tune in and
therefore tune out things that are
adjacent sound wise yes a critical
capacity and so creatures with very
Acuity so for us you know we can point
an ear by pointing our head but can't
isolate a sound that way
or at least not very well but an animal
that can point one ear you know and
swing it so it points in only that
direction and therefore Tunes in you
know the same way you pivot your eyes to
look you know at somewhere with your
fovea I think it it has that function
and so why we don't have them is because
we don't have the ability to move our
ears separately and
um and tune into a particular sound
um but I think we find it cute
because
creatures that do have them
um are acute you know a fox is a very
lovely creature and it has some very
pointy ears
um and so we infer but what that seems
circular to me why do we find them cute
well we find lots of things
you'd because they trigger
um
yeah I was going to say because it
triggers you know
you know rental
uh reflexes but I don't know yeah I
don't know I think you know they're
foreign have it yeah I don't quite have
it either and also I realize that some
of the examples I gave um just have um
the pointing up ears but they're not
like Mouse ears aren't pointy they're
rounded
um and you know rabbit ears aren't
pointed they're long they're elongated
but they're not pointed uh but I think
most people would agree that they're
cute too and they also do
yeah they do this independent movement
thing
um
and I can't I honestly having a hard
time visualizing an orc at the moment I
don't remember where their ears are in
their heads
um elves
um yeah it's it's I think that that's
very unlikely to have happened actually
pointed ears that are basically
plastered against the side of your head
unless there is some ability to do this
which you know maybe that is what elves
are supposed to be able to do I don't
know I'm not familiar with elephant I
agree with you that you don't you
shouldn't expect to see the pointed
unless it has a separate reason for
existing the pointedness should go hand
in hand with the ability to Pivot though
unless they've got like the caracal
things on them and it's just a it's a
it's on the character display in the
caracal case I think it is no but
elephant ears with a with the with the
tots on them so they're using the points
too yeah to display their awesomeness to
each other yep yeah I agree yeah
yeah all right
um let's see we have a three-part
question from Echo here
aspirin
acetyl salicylic acid was the miracle
drug oh aspirin acetyl salicylicylic
acid colon was the miracle drug
propaganda about patenting
it's inspired by white willow bark
salicylic acid used by ancient Sumerians
and Egyptians
uh NB hydroxychloroquine is inspired by
Artemisia anoa used in Asia and Africa
against paladism whose use who formerly
discouraged in 2012.
um
with many papers against atromesia anawa
to force people to buy
hydroxychloroquine which is more
concentrated
so I'm getting something out of this
yeah I'm also reading it for some reason
they're not in the right order so I'm
having to jump around here
um so so
I I think well you want to riff a little
bit I'm trying to figure out what uh so
far all I've gotten is that there's a
tendency to propagandize the you know
it's some version of the Pharma game
where there's there's a tendency to
propagandize the usefulness of a
molecule the safety of a molecule well
that's the question was the miracle drug
propaganda this is from last week right
about patenting and if I remember
correctly I think actually it had just
fallen out of patent I think Bayer had
Pat did Aspirin originally and at the
point that the Spanish Flu came it was
just out of patent and so now more
widely available to be produced by
others I think I'm not positive about
that but I think it was not a patent
game so at that point it sounds to me
from the question I I can't speak to
which version it is that maybe acetyl
salicylic acid was their replacement for
salicylic acid from willow bark and that
that might have uh reinvigorated or Prof
provided the opportunity for patenting
so I I don't know the question is did
Bear have a patent at the point that the
Spanish Flu was rampant and I don't know
the answer yeah I think it had just
ended
um but you know the game with uh
the two forms of chloroquine or
hydroxychloroquine
I didn't know that but it doesn't
surprise me yeah it's true you know it
and the fact that that game is played
isn't
um
inherently egregious but it is our job
you know that this is what organizations
like the FDA are supposed to be are
supposed to be monitoring and and
taken care of no that's that's what
they're supposed to be doing right of
course people will do this I think I of
course people will do it I do think it's
egregious well yeah but that's what like
that's what the out that's what the
organizations like the FDA that's that's
what the governmental organizations are
supposed to take care of well but we are
we're caught in a bind where we have the
profit motive
in places that it does not belong
right if the job of making people
healthy is
um really what medicine is about then
the point is
the move of trying to convince people to
take this molecule rather than that
molecule because you have a patent on it
it should be illegal either this is a
public
phenomenon in which case profit ought to
be taken out of it because health is too
important or its buyer beware and what
we have is the worst of Both Worlds
where we have the patent game uh the
Pharma game we have the capturing of The
Regulators game and uh we are not you
know
what happened to buyer people here in
the era of code
we weren't allowed to beware it was
actually formally declared
misinformative to try to watch out for
your own interests right right to listen
to people who dissented so you know it
is the destruction of the instinct to
make people healthier and the
replacement of that instinct
um by some remote entities desire to
make money and it is absolutely it is
egregious so I want one or the other I
either want to know that I'm you know
getting a sales pitch
that I should ignore it
or I want to know that this has nothing
to do with profit because it would be
impossible for anyone to make one
I don't I don't want them I don't want
to be shamed or noticing that somebody
is making a profit for their mandated
product that is being inflicted on me
despite having been poorly tested by the
very people who are making that money
yeah and that's you being unreasonable
again once again
I'm not sure what to make of this but
I'm gonna I'm gonna read it some two
parts my own research
um asks did Elton
Mis interpret the population Cycles are
the population Cycles in active
colonization mechanism
um where in population Cycles are called
Invasion pulses so could they be an
active mechanism
well I don't know exactly what this is
referring to the idea of
overpopulation triggering the
exploration for new territory certainly
makes sense it doesn't
it's missing a step because it is
unnecessary you can build Wanderlust in
at any level of
um
proximity to carrying capacity
if it's desirable having to overshoot
the carrying capacity in order to
motivate people
creatures to move is
um wasteful so it doesn't have the look
of an adaptation the Wanderlust does and
that it would be triggered by
overpopulation but the overpopulation
does not have the look of an adaptation
a totally different topic um
I saw a sticker on a car that read MILF
man I love frogs
with an image of one it reminded me of
someone we know now I'll be looking for
one that begins
Battle of lizards I love leopards
I have to say
um I think civilization went wrong and
possibly unrecoverably that was the
moment that MILF yeah that was the
branching Point such a Despicable
concept yeah
um
that anyway I don't necessarily need to
see it resurrected around love of frogs
but it is better than the uh the
original meaning
yeah you can be sure that if 2001 was
written in 2023 we'd know Hal's pronouns
man
yeah
uh here's a suggestion on the topic of
AI please consider interviewing Rob
miles from computer file okay you know
you know that I don't okay just
switch on that
we may apply gender to things seen as
conscious because we have two sexes yep
absolutely let me impose it yeah we
impose it I I think it's an I think it's
an error
but I'm not certain of that it fee it
feels like it opens up the room
for confusion and then to be for that
confusion to be taken advantage of as it
is but um but I think that may be part
of
it I think you're I think you're right
and I also think that there is
potentially a protective
going through the formal exercise of
making sure that you call the AI it yeah
and not he or she
is probably useful because it forces you
to consciously recognize that you don't
know what that thing is but if there's
one thing it isn't it's
um he or she it's not it's not a
descendant of the same tree of life
right
yes that's right
do llms not just help us understand the
limits of language as a culturally
evolved model of reality there are other
modes of communication
kinda
um
the thing about language is that it's so
far outstrips the next nearest
competitor
and even to the extent that you can come
up with an argument for the next nearest
competitor being better than I'm giving
it credit for
it's in the context of creatures that
have language and so yes you know I can
learn to communicate something very
complex to you without saying anything
but it's not as if that does not come on
a substrate of having spoken
so anyway the thing the thing about
language is it allows you to transmit
abstractions between Minds so that they
can be parallel processed nothing else
does that right at least not uh
regularly and if something else does it
it can't you know you can't pick any
abstraction and convey it
some other mode you might have an
abstraction that you could convey but
uh in in other words
language is the thing that makes humans
special is it totally without an analog
elsewhere in the animal kingdom no but
the point is the difference between
language and the next nearest uh
counterpart is so great that although it
is a difference in degree the difference
in degree is so large as to make it a
separate
function that does not feel like I've
said that very clearly but no I think
this is I think this is important I
didn't
I didn't understand the question the
same way you did but I think
I think what you're saying here is is
very important there are of course many
modes of communication and back to where
we started with the Q a you know the
various ways that we sense the universe
are you know reflective of real things
that can be sensed in the universe so
um but you know this the sensing is
entirely receptive and communication of
course requires both the singular and a
receiver
and
uh language which
you know now can sometimes be visual but
usually is using
um audio
requires not just that there's the
ability to produce but also to receive
the sound and then all of the all of the
complexity there
um
you know smell just doesn't have the
complexity possible for it too oh yeah
um you know touch could communicate a
tremendous amount but
um the the
abstraction is not
is not there you'd have to use language
you could convey things by you know
making letters with your fingers but the
point is you're then borrowing from the
language module
so it's really it's inconceivable
that another mode does what language
does and I would also just point out
that this is obvious
in the sense that it takes a human being
you know
a decade to gain even moderate facility
with
this mode
right that's not idle time that's not
like you know the tongue takes that long
to develop to be able to make the sounds
that's you have to learn the subtleties
of how to convey things and it's not
easy right it's a slow process yeah
okay let's do two more questions here
what
is the evolutionary explanation for
psychiatric conditions
what are the evolutionary advantages
of psychiatric conditions
I'm such a giant category you got to be
very careful not to assume that because
there is something called a psychiatric
condition that you assume it's an
adaptation the thing about adaptations
is they are the result of a process that
allows them to spread and to be
augmented
and many of the things that we call
psychological conditions are
dysfunctions
they are the opposite of adaptations and
you know it's very tempting
because somebody who has schizophrenia
May produce something creative to say oh
it's an adaptation and we treat it as if
it's a dysfunction now it's a genuine
dysfunction which doesn't mean that it
doesn't open doors every now and again
but
um but anyway there's a category error
with adaptations and and dysfunction
okay but still
um
explanation
so it may just be dysfunctional right
well yes although
we make the argument in our book that
many of these disorders have let's take
schizophrenia for example as
um
a surprising overlap with the symptoms
of sleep
that is to say when you sleep
you uh May believe that a narrative is
unfolding that isn't you have
conversations with people who don't
exist
um you may be paranoid that someone is
after you uh all of those things if they
happen to you when you're asleep you
then gifts followed up by usually
Amnesia there was paralysis while it
happened and so you just kind of ignore
it but the point is no you were either
Stark raving mad while you were asleep
or there's an Adaptive explanation for
it while you're asleep and it happens
that the same stuff affects you
when you're awake and when it does we
call it schizophrenia or hallucinations
that are the result of having taken an
entheogen the fact that those three
things have the same set of symptoms
um is suggestive that schizophrenia and
probably
uh
bipolar disorder are
the dream circuitry which is adaptive
running at a time that it shouldn't when
you're awake you think bipolar too yeah
I do
um
in any case something like that you've
got an Adaptive circuit running where it
shouldn't
right
um and that that would explain the
pattern and the hint of an adaptation in
something that's clearly
um dysfunctional
all right final question
is there an evolutionary case to be made
against humans eating bugs
um
is there an evolutionary case clearly
not because there are many cultures that
do eat their share of bugs and you know
even so sometimes other people share as
well
hmm
you said they their Sheriff bugs even a
lot of us aren't eating any bugs they
probably are shooting our share of bugs
yes
um and you know uh our culture to the
extent that our culture is even a thing
uh eats bugs of the sea
arthropods of the sea yeah uh even if
not terrestrial insects not technically
insects but arthropods yes yes
absolutely so anyway none of this is an
argument for us uh industrializing the
scale of bug production and inflicting
it on people with propaganda
um but
no I don't think there's any there can
be no argument against any bug eating
given the number of human cultures in
which some bug eating goes on yeah I
mean I've seen I think we we answered
some question about bug eating before
Insight eating before and someone said
what about the chitin
like I have not looked into it and I
thought well you know it's possible the
chitin isn't good for you that it's you
know it it makes sharp little bits in
your in your gut and might cause some
little micro perforations I don't know
uh on the other hand a lot of the bug
eating that happens say
um in Amazonia for instance tends to be
larval forms right pretty grubby uh very
grubby very very grubby uh or like the
meaty the
the body meat of like big juicy spiders
like tarantulas
yeah
okay I don't I don't eat that I really
don't want to have to eat that I have
you know I have tried some bugs
um I actually just when I was in Mexico
I met a couple people and uh we went to
a Mezcal bar and got a little appetizer
of
it's like deep fried ants or something
and they just it just tasted crunchy
it's like this is fine I don't I don't
think this is bad for me I don't think
it's good for me I think it's like it's
ants yeah I'd rather eat those than
body of a tarantula yeah yeah yeah
translate tarantula farming is slow oh
god um
but anyway yeah you know I I would say
um
a if it's the hard parts of their bodies
there's all kinds of Technologies for
pulverizing Stuff
um but again I
large scale is different than
occasional or yeah long-standing bug
eating Traditions yeah and yeah long
stay I don't there are no cultures
uh I am
highly confident this is true there are
no cultures where insects uh provide the
majority of protein in their diet right
right like there are plenty of cultures
where insects are a regular piece of
their diet or there might even be a few
things that are Delicacies that we would
not regard as Delicacies at all and of
course that's going to be true across
you know for lots of things besides
insects uh but I there's
whereas you know there are lots of
pastoralist cultures that rely on um
having domesticated mammals usually and
eating mostly the Flesh and Blood of
those mammals there aren't dedicated
insectivorous human cultures it's just
not that's not
thing right and there are some cultures
uh that have a taboo against eating
insects like
um the elite of Davos they do not eat
sex they think that we will eat insects
while we are delighting over not owning
anything and being
so happy
oh but some of them would would eat some
some forms in some very specialized uh
contexts we know I think mostly what it
is I mean these are people who who like
escargot oh sure that is very different
um no my feeling is the elite of Davos I
don't eat snails would agree to eat a
very small number of insects in exchange
for our agreeing to own nothing and be
happy that's the circumstances in which
we will find those people eating insects
and otherwise I don't think so
all right we'll be back next week same
time same place
uh with the Q a next week as well
and uh in the meantime check out Natural
Selections check out our book
undergatherer's guide come find us at 11
A.M Pacific time tomorrow Sunday March
it's not going to be the 26th
when at my patreon we have a live
private q a we get to interact with uh
with you guys who are watching live but
then we leave it up uh if you want to
catch it later and
um until then until until we see you
next time be good to the ones you love
be good food and get outside
[Music]